it's a lot better than a lot of people
thought it was going to be let's start
with that it is threat of surprising to
me in some ways that it's done this well
this long because I was taught at the
university chicago and northwestern that
it was terribly important for countries
to have savings and to invest a lot in
the future and i had a lot to do with
how well they're doing well america
today as the lowest savings rate it has
had in many many years at the national
level it's fallen dramatically from 0
ten eleven percent of the gdp as we call
it down to one or two personal savings
rates stunningly have gone from nine
percent of our disposable income to a
minus one percent and we've become very
gifted ardent robust consumers and
borrows and not savers now the big
question is we become huge borrowers as
a country with our very large deficits
we become borrowers at the consumer
level with very hard debt levels and
really lousy savings levels and the big
question i have but the american economy
is not today but it's how long we think
we can continue because we've got some
huge challenges that are coming we have
78 million baby boomers twice the size
of the current generation due to begin
retiring next year we have social
security and medicare that our programs
that are where we made a lot of promises
but we haven't funded them
and we've grossly misled the American
people was such euphemisms as the Social
Security trust fund I argue and it's
oxymoron it shouldn't be trusted and
it's not funded because the money has
already been spent and we haven't
provided for those programs we are
getting to be fancy language we have
something called a current account
deficit which measures our deficits
abroad which is largely the trade
deficit it's now twice as high as a
percentage of the economy as it's ever
been in America's history and we're
borrowing borrowing and borrowing and
becoming dysfunctional II and I think
destructively bet dependent on the long
run on Chinese money and Japanese money
and Asian money and so forth in which
they lend us this money funny thing
about borrowing you have to pay back at
some time and as a country we can't
continue to borrow seven percent of the
whole economy which is what we're
borrowing now for very many years
without looking like a very different
America than we have now so I think the
the economy today is in pretty good
shape though it's getting pretty
turbulent now with housing and housing
is a wonderful example I did quite a
study about 18 months ago and I was
stantly astonished at the number of
people who bought homes no money down
it's called interest on me and then I
was astonished that even though mortgage
rates at the lowest level in 30 years
they've averaged around nine point seven
percent or something like that and now
they're like six people are not taking
long term
mortgages about half of them are taking
what are called adjustable rate
mortgages well one might say gee that's
fine if we have a lot of savings that
we've stacked away and if we aren't
bartling very much for other purposes
that isn't true we're borrowing more as
observer income than we had in many many
years so now we've had this big blowout
of the so called subprime mortgage
market and today I here on the press
that housing prices are falling and so
for it what did we think was going to
happen how are these loans going to get
payback if we don't have any savings are
already heavily borrowed so my concerns
about the economy of this country are
much more in the future and much more of
our culture we had become from one of
the biggest savers in the world and
saving remember as a metaphor for the
future we become the biggest consumers
and borrowers in the world which is kind
of another way of saying I want it all I
want it now and I don't want to give up
anything and kind of to hell with the
future so I am far more concerned with
America's economic future 10 15 20 years
from now than I am what happens over the
next six months
I am planning to take my bounty from
Blackstone going public a lot of it and
it's quite a windfall and set up a will
turn out to be a very large foundation
and because I've been boring people
relentlessly for the last 20 30 years
about some of these problems I'm going
to take a number of these problems that
are on what I call undeniable and
unsustainable and yet politically
untouchable because of the political
culture we now live in where it's
considered almost politically terminal
to ever ask anybody to give up anything
or pay for anything and you know I want
more and more and more and I I want it
now and to take these issues which i
think our serious threat to America's
future and take those issues where
there's a huge gap between what we
should be doing and what we could be
doing and what we are or not doing and
figure out how at the margin a major
foundation might be able to make a
difference when I think a young people
today and I think of what we're leaving
them 10 15 20 years from now you remind
me of that old joke in the philosophy
class where the professor asked the
students which is worse ignorance
ignorance or apathy and some poor kid
from the back of the class says I don't
know and I don't care well I think it's
an interesting question is there an
exciting way that we could get the young
people of this country aware and their
parents because I refuse to believe that
parents of suddenly
become cold and indifferent to their own
kids and grandparents I think they've
been deceived and misinformed and dis
informed and so forth so we have a
political system today for example where
the elderly are unbelievably well
represented the American Association of
Retired Persons as 38 dues paying them
three million dues paying members they
write more they lobby more they call
more and by and large that's not too
unfair to say a lot of their programs
are we want more even though any
reasonable standard as I say some of
these challenges are unsustainable we
can't we're not going to be able to meet
the promises that we made so on the one
hand we have these this culture of our
ethic of shared sacrifice being kind of
a dirty word not wanting to give up
anything we have political organizations
who are dominant in representing one age
group and the young people who are all
about the future are somehow being
slipped this huge check hidden check i
might add for our free lunch and nobody
seems to be doing anything about it so i
would like to gather together the
student and the young leaders of this
country and take a day or two and say
you try to give you the biggest best run
zone i can in half a dozen areas of the
economy and fiscally and what the world
looks like and then I want you to
contemplate that because it's not my
future at yours I'm 81 years old I lord
knows I don't need anything more and ask
you what are the best ways to do
something about it and should we have an
American Association of young people and
their parents for example because until
this democracy gets educate
it gets informed which is the first
requirement and then get active and
motivated not much is going to happen on
these problems unless there's a huge
crisis and will be a very costly crisis
when it hits so that's a long winner to
answer how I feel about the economy i
I'm much more concerned about the
long-term picture that I am over the
next year or two or three my parents
generation the greatest generation for
example fought the most costly war in
history costly in every sense of that
word they built international
institutions Marshall Plan and so forth
which was central to the world getting
restored they had GI Bill of Rights for
all the returning veterans went to
college they rebuilt the infrastructure
of this country but they didn't ask me
to pay for it they paid for it because
they were willing to invest in the
future and that meant saving and that
meant consuming less I tell these
University audiences I think a careful
study of your sociologist of your social
psychologists of your political
scientists of your economists of your
historians and say what was it during
those early times in we're more
Americans than I'm afraid today had a
clear sense of the future and a
responsibility for it and what led us to
this notion I'm going to grab what I can
and the government owes me this and the
government owes me that and kind of to
hell with other people are to hell with
the future to hell with who and how
we're going to pay for all this now why
did that come about
what led to this boomer mentality you
know but I wanted it all I got to enjoy
it and I have a dear friend who is an
aspect of the medical profession he's
kind of complaining that he's not a
millionaire or multi made in her or
whatever and I said well you know one
way people become millionaires as they
saved and they invest but he's got to
have his small airplane that he flies on
the weekend is he points out to me it's
not a jet and i said well i understand i
don't have to jet either but and oh you
know i need to have fun because i worked
so hard over a week and I need a Porsche
car you know and so forth and that is
the Boomer mentality that were kind of
dealing with here and I don't really
know what led from saving and investing
into the future which consuming and
borrowing now did America get
disenchanted by the Vietnam War the tour
of this country part did we get torn
apart by the assassinations of
presidents and presidents brothers and
Martin Luther King and riots in the
streets and I was as I say I was working
on this problem in Chicago it was a
terrifying sight to see and did somehow
the bonds that unite us and heelys lead
to the current situation i'm not sure
but i have never seen a time when there
is so much bitterness and partisanship
and paralysis as we have today in our
government I mean nothing we went
through important areas
areas where the Republican leadership in
the Democratic leadership I United for a
much larger cause namely the nation's
interest we've had very little of that
recently so i'm putting i don't know
what all the reasons are I just know
there's been a a really major shift i
think if i may just to insult your
medium it entirely possible that
television has had its impact for
example i used to watch my children I
the mire there wasn't television and
they turn on the TV and pounded into
their heads here's this toy they had to
have this is this dress they gotta have
this is and we've developed a kind of a
indulgent instant gratification
consumption largesse that has become
part of our culture and I don't I don't
know all the reasons for it but
certainly the presence of such an
effective medium in television is
probably one of the one of the fastest